talk traffic now  in south clark county right now near  laughlin u.s 95 is closed that's  basically right at the nevada california  border sort of near needles there's a  town there called uh there's another  little community around that area  basically there's a very serious crash  roads are closed traffic is being  diverted we have no other details  available right now but if you're  heading south on us 95 just be aware it  is closed now sometimes that route is a  long way to get around the backups on  i-15 during busy holiday weekends like  this here is a live look at i-15 this is  the freeway right at prim you can see  all the spots up there by prim in the  background there looks like traffic is  flowing pretty well for the moment we'll  certainly keep an eye on things all  throughout the day